Mit klaren Worten richtet sich UN-Generalsekretär
António Guterres
an den syrischen Machthaber Baschar al-Assad.
Angesichts der Lage der Zivilbevölkerung in Ost-Ghuta fordert Guterres einen sofortigen Stopp der Angriffe.
"Ich bin zutiefst getroffen vom Leiden der zivilen Bevölkerung in Ost-Ghuta,
400.000 Menschen erleben dort die Hölle auf Erden.
Vor unseren Augen spielt sich eine humanitäre Katastrophe ab und ich finde nicht,
dass wir dies einfach so geschehen lassen können."
Nach dem Willen Schwedens und Kuwaits soll der UN-Sicherheitsrat bereits heute über
eine Resolution abstimmen, die eine 30-tägige
Feuerpause in Syrien fordert.
Diese soll humanitäre Hilfslieferungen in
die umkämpfte Region
sowie die Evakuierung von Verletzten ermöglichen.
Allen internationalen Appellen zum Trotz bombardiert
die syrische Regierung seit mehreren Tagen die Region Ost-Ghuta.
Assad scheint entschlossen, die Rebellenhochburg
unweit der Hauptstadt Damaskus zurückzuerobern.
Nach Angaben der Syrischen Beobachtungsstelle
für Menschenrechte kamen bei den Kämpfen
in den vergangenen Tagen mehr als 300 Zivilisten
ums Leben – darunter viele Kinder.